[Music]
what's the worry here nick you've lost
some of your talent as an actor
no
what did he say he says he loves you but
he went in a different direction
i'm done
i'm quitting acting tell the trades it
was a tremendous
honor to be a part of storytelling and
myth-making ah [ __ ] man i'm driving
through the hills i'm sorry one more
time
we got another offer it's a million
bucks it's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party i would never
do that it's the easiest gig ever you
play yourself what do we know about this
guy anyway he's into something strange
it's not like he's gonna want you to
suck his dick or [ __ ] his wife or watch
you watch him [ __ ] his wife i wouldn't
think so
welcome to my orca mr cage the guy that
owns this house what's his name cubby is
harvey gonna want me to uh
playing cubby
nick cage
god this place is stunning what is your
favorite movie that's one of those
questions that's impossible to answer
you can't just limit it to one imagine
me and you i do
is it too much
is this supposed to be me
it's grotesque
i'll give you twenty thousand four
[Music]
i'm in position i think that's the actor
nick cage nick h i love you
have you seen crow's suit i'm 44 years
old why the [ __ ] would i see croods too
i've seen face-off and conair
you guys won we're with central
intelligence do you know who you're
spending time with one of the most
ruthless men on the face of this planet
i need you to help the us government
[Music]
find a way into that room nick
i can see myself doing more of this
stuff i think i might have a real gift
for it good because we got another
mission for you no no no no no no
your friend is working for the us
government don't lie to me
are those my golden guns they're my
golden guns i don't want to kill you
we're the last person i want to kill i
love you i love you
wow cage
[Music]
you